[Music]
what's up y'all as always welcome to the
channel today we're jumping back into a
rather important topic and that is our
examination of the Adventist Jesus if
you haven't seen the previous Parts the
link to those is in the description box
down below so if you saw the last part
you'll remember that the SDA Church
erroneously claims that Jesus was
inaugurated to be a priest at his
Ascension this is foundational to their
teaching regarding the investigative
judgment we looked at how Hebrews 2
talks about how Jesus functioned as a
priest in the offering up of himself as
a propitiatory sacrifice at Calvary
something that was clearly prior to the
Ascension we also looked at how the
Ascension of Christ was the inauguration
as king of kings and Lord of lords not
high priest being after the order of
melchisedec he continued as a priest in
a king where he functions as both
simultaneously from his throne which is
precisely what I want to keep Drilling
in on today you'll recall the SDA
inspired pen claimed that Jesus would
begin truly functioning as a king at a
point in the future at the close of of
the investigative judgment that's
because she had this to say in the great
controversy regarding Christ's Priestly
role those who are living upon the Earth
when the intercession of Christ shall
cease in the sanctuary above are to
stand in the sight of a holy God without
a mediator their robes must be spotless
their characters must be purified from
sin by the blood of sprinkling through
the grace of God and their own diligent
effort they must be conquers in the
battle with evil while the investigative
judgment is going forward in heaven
while while the sins of penitent
Believers are being removed from the
sanctuary there is to be a special work
of purification of putting away of sin
among God's people upon Earth this work
is more clearly presented in the
messages of Revelation 14 so they teach
that Christ will cease functioning as a
mediator between God and man at the
close of the investigative judgment in
which as we saw in the last part he will
take off his Priestly garments and put
on his kingly garments once this happens
one will have to stand before God
Almighty who in their system is only the
father without Jesus as your mediator
your character must be spotless through
having confessed every sin such that
Jesus could deal with it using his blood
during the investigative judgment hence
what she is getting at regarding the
purification from sin by the blood of
sprinkling but very clearly she claims
that Jesus will cease being a priest and
doing the work of mediation for people
in the future so yall know the drill by
now question of the day is that what
scripture teaches first in Hebrews 5
we're told something interesting
regarding Jesus's priesthood notice what
the author tells
us so also Christ did not exalt himself
to be made a high priest but was
appointed by him who said to him you are
my son today I have begotten you as he
says also in another place you are a
priest Forever After the order of
malchis DEC in the days of his flesh
Jesus offered up prayers and
supplications with loud cries and tears
to him who is able to save him from
death and he was heard because of his
reverence although he was a son he
learned obedience through what he
suffered and being made perfect he
became the source of Eternal salvation
to all who obey him being designated by
God a high priest after the order of
melchisedek so the author follows the
same pattern he has throughout the whole
book and that is a compare and contrast
of what makes Jesus better in this case
better than the levitical priests the
levitical priests could not exalt
themselves to the office of priest in
essence an individual levite couldn't
just declare himself to be a priest in
the service of God and start working
well just like in the levitical order
Christ did not exalt himself to the
office of a priest he had an oath spoken
over him by his father where the author
then cites Psalm 110 which is the oath
that was spoken over Christ by his
father who said Jesus the son is a
priest for how long
forever
for which means that from the
inauguration of Christ as priest and
onward even if we wanted to grant that
it was at his Ascension his priesthood
function will not cease which should
clue Us in on the work that Jesus is
currently doing and how that work does
not make sense in the Adventist Paradigm
nevertheless notice what the author says
in verse 7 that while he was here on
Earth he offered up prayers and
supplications with loud cries and tears
to the father who could save him from
Death so now the author takes our minds
to the Garden of Gethsemane where Jesus
offered up what his high Priestly prayer
which once again shows us that Christ
was functioning as a priest and already
had his anointing as such prior to his
Ascension what Christ offered up in his
high Priestly prayer in John 17 was not
just prayers and supplications but also
himself he was heard we are told because
of his reverence and perfect obedience
but then the author sheds more light on
this by continuing into chapter 7
specifically josing why Christ's role as
a priest is superior to that of the
Levites notice what he says Hebrews 7
11-22 now if Perfection had been
attainable through the levitical
priesthood for under it the people
received the law what further need would
there have been for another priest to
arise after the order of mchis
rather than one named after the order of
Aaron for when there is a change in the
priesthood there is necessarily A change
in the law as well for the one of whom
these things are spoken belong to
another tribe from which no one has ever
served at the altar for it is evident
that our Lord was descended from Judah
and in connection with that tribe Moses
said nothing about priests this becomes
even more evident when another priest
arises in the likeness of malized who
has become a priest not on the basis of
a legal requirement concerning bodily
descent but by the power of an
indestructible life for it is witnessed
of him you are a priest Forever After
the order of melkisedek for on the one
hand a former commandment is set aside
because of its weakness and uselessness
for the law made nothing perfect but on
the other hand a better hope is
introduced through which we draw near to
God and it was not without an oath for
those who formerly became priests were
made such without an oath but this one
was made a priest with an oath by the
one who said to him the Lord has sworn
and will not change his mind you are a
priest forever this makes Jesus the
guarantor of a better Covenant the
former priests were many in number
because they were prevented by Death
from continuing in office but he holds
his priesthood permanently because he
continues forever consequently he is
able to save to the uttermost those who
draw near to God through him since he
always lives to make intercession for
them wow so there was a lot of meat
there but some of that includes being
told that Perfection was not attainable
through through the levitical priesthood
if it were there would have been no need
for God to foretell of one who would
come from the tribe of Judah of which
the scriptures say nothing about priests
but the one from the tribe of Judah
would be after the order of melkisedek
and how did this happen not on the basis
of ceremonial commands which belong to
the fleshly line of Aaron but on the
basis of his indestructible life where
the author then again cites Psalm 110
and the oath spoken over Christ that he
would be a priest for how long forever
and the former priest were many in
number because they were prevented from
continuing due to being mortal Fallen
men but Jesus continues as a priest
forever because he will never die which
is why he always lives to make
intercession for his people which makes
Jesus the guarantor of a better Covenant
where he is able to save to the
uttermost those who come to God through
him when Ellen White states that the
mediation and intercessory work of
Christ will cease not only does she
contradicts scripture but she
demonstrates the aous system has a very
weak understanding of what all the
mediation of Christ entails when we are
told that there's one mediator between
God and man the man Christ Jesus we get
a glimpse into how the God man himself
is the bridge between man and God by
virtue of him being both this is why the
Incarnation is a foundational part of
the work of redemption to Be an
Effective mediator Christ had to be
truly God and truly man mediators
function as a goet who can represent the
interests of both parties as God Christ
brings both Justice and mercy to bear on
our relationship with our maker as man
Christ brings the perfect human
obedience we need in order to be
reconciled to God such that he is able
to present himself before the father for
all of those that are in him such that
they can then be seen as righteous in
him at the end of the day all avenus
roads lead back to 1844 and this area is
most certainly not an exception Jesus
was not inaugurated as a priest at his
Ascension he is not in heaven dealing
with blood in a second phase of
atonement that started in 1844 as we saw
in part four the author of Hebrews goes
to Great Lengths to explain that Christ
is seated unlike the Levites who never
sat down because the work of dealing
with sin was never accomplished Jesus on
the other hand put sin Away by the
single sacrifice of himself at Calvary
this act of mediation by Christ for his
people will never cease and thank God
for that he is able to save to the
uttermost meaning perfectly and he will
be successful at that and keeping those
he mediates for even into eternity as we
continue examining the finer details we
continue to see that the abous Jesus is
a very different different figure than
the Jesus of both history and scripture
and only the true Christ is able to save
to the
uttermost hey thanks for watching if you
like content like this and you want to
support us make sure to visit answering
adventism tocom where you can donate
access more resources and even sign up
for our monthly newsletter you can also
connect with us on both Facebook and
Instagram as always until next time God
[Music]
bless
what